Providence Canyon a couple of hours
drive from Atlanta is known as Georgia's
little Grand Canyon this network of
gorges and gullies reaches over 40
metres deep and it's beautiful
even without the artificial saturation
boost that a lot of photographers and
give it this is known as one of the
seven natural wonders of Georgia there
is just one problem with that
description though this is man-made by
accident this is a scar in the earth and
it's a scar that'll take a very long
time to heal the ground here is made of
unconsolidated sediment that means I was
standing on loose sand and clay that was
deposited tens of millions of years ago
on what was then the seafloor it's
stable of course but it's never been
compacted into solid rock or cemented
together by geology and time it's not
going to collapse but if you draw a line
from say desert sand where nothing
sticks together
to solid rock the sort of thing that
miners have to blast with dynamite the
ground here is definitely on this end of
the scale for a long way down tree root
systems grass and other plants all help
stabilize it and that was fine for
millions of years and through most of
human history until settlers manifested
their destiny halt over this continent
at the start of the 19th century this
whole area was flat forest and none of
these canyons were here settlers cleared
the area of all his trees and plowed the
soil for agriculture either they didn't
know about crop rotation and soil
management or perhaps they didn't care
seeing a whole continent laid out before
them soon the little drainage paths that
rainwater took after storms started to
erode and become bigger and bigger and
bigger wood soil like this it only took
a few decades before this landscape
formed a century and a half later new
trees are starting to stabilize some of
it but it's still changing and eroding
the park management has to move these
fences occasionally sometimes they'll
find one of the spires out there has
just fallen after heavy rain there are
strict no climbing warnings here because
well the rock you're holding on to could
just fall away and dissolve in your hand
so my question is should this count as a
natural wonder it is part of nature peep
do come to wonder at it all those colors
are from the different minerals that are
in the soil so this is a look back
through with those millions of years of
geological history and those millions of
years are unquestionably natural but
exposing them that was very much human
so I'm hoping the microphone picked up
that noise because as soon as I turn my
camera off
there's a massive noise I'm fairly sure
that was a rock fall from this cliff
which is worrying it's probably fine
[Applause]